Heupido yo, señor rueda, que Faga,
o sea, 1 papel de Presidente de todos y de todas,
y que no vaya con 1 posición de parte,
que busque 1 posición
de país para poder avanzar
en todas las competencias que necesita galiza,
Mais competencias con donación
da débeda e 1 Nuevo modelo de financiamiento
que realmente se echa beneficioso
para este país.
Yo quiero proponer yo, señor rueda,
que avancemos en esa posición ambiciosa
ovénega. Tengo 1 folla de ruta muy Clara,
sabemos que o mayor para los intereses de este país
sería contar guachávedos,
no soscartos. Tenemos 1 marche muy amplia para mejorar
o financiamiento galego
si hay ambición
y si se VA, y cuna posición
de país
si realmente quiere defenderos intereses de este país,
no estemos toda vocación de traballar para mejorar
a vida 2 galegos e das galegas